Caroline de Camaret bonjour c'est la
présidente pro-européenne Maya sans
doute qui a détaillé ce plan présumé de
déstabilisation que les Russes démentent
oui déjà la fermeture de l'espace aérien
mais par hermoldova c'est très
significatif vendredi dernier ministère
de la Défense à détecté un projectile
probablement tiré depuis la mer Noire
ayant survolé donc la Moldavie de
village en particulier pour aller
s'écraser en Ukraine l'ambassadeur de
Russie avait alors été convoqué dans la
foulée et à partir de là hier la
présidente accusé Moscou de préparer de
violentes attaques de son pays Moscou
qui dément qui parle de désinformation
venue de l'Ukraine parce que le
président
ukrainien veut le dire Zelinski a dit la
semaine dernière qu'il avait intercepté
un certain nombre de documents qui fait
la terre d'un plan de déstabilisation ce
que de ce qu'on peut appeler un coup
d'état puisqu'il s'agit de d'attaque
d'édifice et étatique et de prise
d'otage par des saboteurs au passé
militaire camouflés en civil alors dans
ce contexte et bien la fameuse très très
proéenne présidente a annoncé un projet
de législatif pour donner au procureur
et aux services de renseignement les
instruments nécessaires pour convaincre
combattre pardon les risques pour la
sécurité nationale cette ex République
de 2 millions 600 000 euros ex des
République soviétiques 2,6 millions
d'habitants pardon elle a elle est
située entre la Roumanie et l'Ukraine et
elle a pris à ce virage pro-occidental
qui inquiète Moscou et qui peut-être est
en train de faire bouger Moscou même
des régions que l'on voit ici à l'est du
pays contrôlé par les soldats russes
depuis maintenant plusieurs années la
Moldavie qui se dirige vers l'Union
européenne puisqu'elle est candidate à
l'adhésion est-ce que ça peut la
protéger contre une déstabilisation de
la part des Russes déjà la Moldavie elle
a bénéficié de ce qui se passait en
Ukraine parce que grâce à l'Ukraine en
quelque sorte entre entre guillemets
mais tout de même grâce à l'Ukraine elle
a eu une candidature Express aussi à
l'Union européenne et son statut de
candidat a été reconnu en même temps que
l'Ukraine en juin dernier ce qui était
un peu inespéré mais vraisemblablement
c'est un pays quand même qui vous le
voyez est très tourné vers l'UE qui est
très démocratique aussi à la différence
au nord de l'Ukraine de la Biélorussie
très autocratique on le sait bien mais
elle n'est elle n'est pas encore dans
l'Union européenne donc ça ne la protège
pas par une clause justement
d'intervention elle n'est pas non plus
dans l'OTAN donc elle n'est pas protégée
militairement et puis on voit bien que
la Russie est fait œuvre d'instabilité
politique comment et bien d'abord vous
l'avez dit avec cette région séparatiste
de Transnistrie avec un important stock
de munitions donc et une population
effectivement plus pro russe
présence de soldats aussi ça inquiète
évidemment les habitants de de cette
Moldavie il y a aussi des pannes
d'électricité massive suite à des
frapperus sur tous les sites
énergétiques ukrainiens et puis qui
distribuait tout le gaz de ce pays
a coupé les robinets à hauteur de la
moitié donc à partir de là ça a généré
de la crise politique la première
ministre Natalia gravita a démissionné à
la suite de ça en disant qu'elle avait
un manque de soutien et de confiance
dans le pays et elle a été remplacée
finalement par l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur un nouveau Premier ministre
toujours pro européen Dorine riccian et
la présidente donc les pro-européenne
l'assume mais c'est qu'il y a des
dangers bien réels à cela et attend de
voir si Moscou a des intentions néfastes
pour on sait bien qu'on est en période
où Moscou pourrait déclencher une grande
offensive à l'approche de la date
anniversaire du 24 février un an de
l'invasion du flan est est-ce que elle
pourrait justement chercher à
déstabiliser la Moldavie ce qui
ouvrirait un deuxième front pour les
Européens pour venir au sauvetage aussi
de ce pays bon on en est pas là et la
Moldavie vient de réouvrir de rouvrir
son espace aérien nous dire Reuter c'est
plutôt rassurant merci en tout cas pour
ces éléments de contexte